let's take a moment to revisit
the problem solving framework that we
started with.
Now that we've performed
the analysis and
run the linear regression model, we need
to validate the results of the model.
In other words, is there a way to
measure how good the model is?
Or in this case,
is the linear expression we
calculated a good fit of our data?
Using the CORREL function, we can
calculate the correlation coefficient
of the data set, or the variable r.
The range of r is from -1 to +1.
The closer r is to +1 or -1,
the better correlation between x and y.
To learn more about
correlation coefficients,
see the link in the resources below.
In our example, the value of r is 0.987,
indicating a strong correlation.
While strong correlation is good,
we really want to know how
well the data fits our line.
Fortunately, we can get a sense of how
good the formula is at approximating
the data by calculating the coefficient
of the determination or R squared.
R squared is the coefficient
between 0 and 1.
R squared is interpreted as the percent
of variance in observations
that is explained by the model.
An r squared value close to one would
mean that nearly all variance in
the target variable is
explained by the model.
An r squared value close to
zero would mean that nearly
none of the variance in the target
variable is explained by the model.
An r squared value greater than 0.7
is considered to be a strong model.
In practice, an r squared value of 0.5
or greater is usually pretty good.
An r squared less than 0.3 is
generally agreed to not be useful.